hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slo-mo
guys this video is sponsored by kiwico
who as you may know we're rather fond of
on this channel they create Hands-On
experiments and activities you can do at
home to get kids excited about learning
I'm going to be taking inspiration from
this here bubble machine and in a very
slow-mo guys fashion escalating it to
make some absolutely massive bubbles to
be honest I just want to put you in a
bubble I think that'll be a good video I
think so too I'm not going to fit in
this so
I've created this
done some engineering of your own yeah
all right why don't you show me what
you've got
all right what's that that is our bubble
solution what I made earlier it mostly
is water distilled water is best and
detergent and a little bit of glycerin
for some extra spice the way it works is
the water molecules have quite a strong
attraction to each other and the
detergent gets in between the water
molecules rude I know
and that decreases the surface tension
which allows the bubbles to form by
creating a very thin film so all we need
really now is this guy
which is what we're going to be making
our bubbles with and somewhere to go and
stand so let's go to the pool
the pool
okay yes it is exactly what it looks
like it's a bit of plastic sheeting with
a hula hoop and a saucepan in it it just
looks like somewhere okay chucked away a
sauce but in a wet bin all right all
right it is incredibly effective though
before you scoff and laugh at me oh yeah
look at the state of this action here
what colors are getting on the side of
that
decent eh very decent the idea is that
I'm going to stand on the saucepan and
you will lift the hula hoop up with the
solution and I'll be inside the bubble
love it I think we should start by
filming it a thousand frames a second in
4k what do you think great idea all
right Dan is this the first time you've
stood on a saucepan in a load of bubbles
I think so I think I can count on my
hands yeah yeah may not be the last
because I don't know how good I am of
this here we go
that was the worst one I've ever done
that was cool yeah you went for the slow
technique this time went really slow it
was uh I was worried about my first
technique you can see here as it gets
higher the definition in the edges
really start showing
yeah it's also weird because if you go
slowly the bubble sort of creeps in yeah
it like squishes me it's like closing it
around yeah yeah yeah so it's like a
balance between speed and
um
my face too I'm just bewildered you're
mesmerized aren't you
yeah
oh
you can see where it all meets on one
side it's like a glittery curtain
isn't it
that was such a range of emotion then
whoa that was cool
all right all right ready
you're poised ready to poke
[Laughter]
so fast isn't it yeah I think like how
fast that actually is that's so quick
okay so you've had the excellent idea
that I poke it
if it starts popping from the back
you'll surely end at the front right
bubble physics yeah
you're initiating the pop all right here
we go
oh
that's so weird
it looks like really stringy doesn't it
it's like very gelatinous yeah maybe we
could get you out there too just do it
against black
oh
I saw about three frames of that but it
looked pretty good
it's like at the very last minute it's
like it creases yeah it's like fabric
look
like bends on itself because it's run
out of all the elasticity it had before
it's just like that's it yeah it's like
a wrinkly jelly layer
you can see the rapid movement in the
film
like look here it's stationary it's very
slow speeding up now and then it
crinkles so you actually see inside the
film is moving and then all the film
like collapses on itself it's honestly
so much going on
I think
we swap camera
a bit of speed we'll go TMX
we'll go really fast just on that front
moment
all right in order to see slightly more
detail on the front of each pop I've
switched to the Phantom TMX 7510 the
fastest Phantom that currently exists
but we're only going to be about 20 000
frames a second because I think any
slower is going to be looking like a a
painting
that's your poke I'm gonna go
all right hold it there
okay ready yep
my face
you know how when like uh sometimes like
a magician like in a show will go like
Bing that's what it looks like
that's really cool perfectly even the
way it
escapes isn't it yeah it seems to like
the temperature distant from your finger
at every Point yeah that's like
different
now it's starting to Trail off but
initially
I can't even see there's a bubble there
apart from that reflection off the light
yeah you wouldn't be able to tell
and then suddenly did you you've pushed
against it there was a little bit there
was a little bit of press on it that you
never would see with the human eye a
little bit of Bones you've put you've
pushed it look
you start pushing it here and it pops
here wow
what it does to your hand like there's
light on your hand
oh it moves the light and then it gives
you like a little Rainbow swish across
the it's like a prism yeah
it almost looks like your fingers moving
so fast it's like a sonic boom like
on the front like
the sound barrier yeah my finger
well I can say that for at least five
seconds I've lived in a bubble
would you come out as a living I mean
I'm living am I not and I'm in a bubble
so I'm living in a bubble
all right we're now at 50 000. just a
tight on the pop and the focus is is
probably a couple of mil a couple of
millimeters not to be confused with Mill
sorry it's an inch part if it's two mil
then it would be probably three thirty
seconds of an inch there you go foreign
[Music]
okay gonna try a ridiculously ambitious
Focus pool
without any real lens equipment usually
you'd have a nice follow Focus here but
I'm just doing it on the lens
it pops so quick it's going to be so
hard yeah I have faith in you
three two one
oh I know it wasn't quite right
three two one pop that was poo I went
too far
three two one pop
was that a real attempt yeah that wasn't
wasn't ready at all oh
so the move on the lens here is from six
feet to three and a half feet in
less than a second which is doable
but it's Landing exactly in the right
place nope
nope
it's pretty good all right let's try it
three two one pop
pretty good that's a pretty damn good
effort actually
look at that look at that folk you can
see you can see your reflection is that
you or is that me in there like around
the corner oh no that's me that's you
I'm in this shot
so if we lose all of the backside
Reflections so these lights are gone I'm
still there from these lights and then
you just crinkle up into nothing you
just like fold it away
you just become a wrinkle that's so
interesting
just so much more going on than I
thought
Just Can't Get Enough can you
I was lucky because I've still got about
10 liters left it doesn't really get
reset till the end of time yeah I really
enjoyed some of that footage I feel like
we've done bubbles before but we've
never done them that slow and with that
level of detail like so close to the
point we can see the front of the pop
it's so weird looking this this bubble
mixture as well it seemed to be quite
wrinkly and weird like a lot of the ones
I've seen before they pop like all
around at the same time these ones
definitely had like a film going on yeah
it's like fabricy towards the end
hopefully you enjoyed that video big
thanks once again to kiwico for
sponsoring it if you like what you saw
you can visit the kiwico store and
explore the different projects that they
offer they have a range of science
technology engineering art and maths
crates for kids of all ages that might
even Inspire big experiments like ours
and if you want to give kids even more
Hands-On fun you definitely should check
out their subscriptions so kids can
receive a brand new project to work on
every single month in my case I've been
using my bubble machine to entertain
this cat
use code slo-mo guys or click on the
link in the description for a special
offer thank you very much for watching
make sure you subscribe if you like
slowbo very distracting
[Laughter]
and we'll see you in the next video
endless fun